[Music]
looks like the killer gutted the victim
strangling with his own intestines and
then dumped the body in the river we're
dealing with one
sick son of a [ __ ] you wanted me home
to see a tv cartoon show
finally back to spider-man cartoons
retrospective part two
hopefully you guys don't mind the way
but you know it's only been like
seven months oh [ __ ] well i've kind of
put off doing this video because of all
the spider-man cartoons out there
these two are the ones that i had the
least to say about they're not shows i'm
particularly passionate about due to any
emotional connection with them nor are
they misunderstood little time capsules
like the 60 series that i'd show in a
new light
they're both exactly what you think they
are at first glance a spider-man show
and gee we need to sell more action
figures let's give him some sidekicks
but before i dig too deep into that
topic i want to thank some amazing
friends who have backed me up by
sponsoring this video
skillshare skillshare is an online
learning community for creatives where
millions come together to take the next
step in the creative journey
skillshare offers thousands of inspiring
classes for creative and curious people
on topics including illustration design
photography
video freelancing and more these classes
include a combination of video lessons
and class projects
these classes are designed to give you
the real world skills that can help you
with pursuing your passions with lessons
and animation
film illustration and graphic design web
development
and plenty of others i'm most interested
in exploring that creative storytelling
class hosted by daniel jose older
it's incredibly affordable at less than
10 dollars a month for an annual
subscription
and is always launching new premium
classes at a time when so many important
conversations are happening in our world
your voice is more essential than ever
explore classes to unlock your
creativity for social good
the first 1000 people to use the link in
my description will get a free trial of
skillshare premium membership
so what are you waiting for join today i
will say it's a little interesting and
strange to me how the 1981 show is often
very looked over by fans of the
character
it's not quite the infamous meme machine
of the turbulent decade
swathed in laughable decisions and
lovably absurd animation
and it's not quite the nostalgic journey
through your childhood that millennials
tend to attribute to two guys one
firestar or the punchless wonder over
here
fun fact that's probably the only joke
i'm gonna make about that because i feel
like it's the most tired
talking point ever and there's so much
more to talk about with this series than
just the censorship
see there i go i'm more interested in
talking about that guy than these guys
i still feel as though it's tradition to
at least try to do a full episode on a
particular subject
so i'll still give an honest attempt at
looking back at these two
unloved middle children of the televised
dead uncle broadcasts
so 80s spider-man um
they had enough money to draw the webs
this time i just but i actually really
dig the look of this show
it's pretty clearly inspired by john
romita jr's artwork from the 80s and
reminds me a lot of his comics from that
time
back in the good old days when every
artist was instructed to keep it all on
model and every spidey comic looked like
ramita senior
so it wasn't distracting when the book
changed art teens in a weird way i kind
of like how consistent things were in
those days
before todd mcfar came in and said just
draw whatever give him 10 million webs
and put his thighs behind his head
everyone go nuts
so this show's visual style feels like a
sign of the times and i appreciate these
character designs
they're simple enough to animate but
more accurate than the series
predecessor
and speaking of accuracy this show has a
pretty strong grasp on its title
character that should be given more
praise
spider-man stays out all night fighting
crime but then falls asleep and forgets
to do his homework
that's on brand i dig it spidey has to
ditch his date early to go catch a
villain and then gets dumped in the most
embarrassing way possible
ah jj what do you say you and i
have a night on the town sure why not
don't work too hard parker who says the
good guy
always gets the girl yeah that tracks
he forgets to lock the door on his
closet and has to figure out a way to
explain the spider-man costume in there
to his aunt may
nailed it i like how this show captures
those little human conflicts that go on
in his day-to-day life
those silly little things that ground
him and make him more relatable than
your average costumed crusader
i can tell you batman doesn't give two
shits what his date thinks
he's more interested in all the sexual
attention he's got going on with that
rambunctious skywalker juggalo iron man
doesn't do homework he just drinks and
sucks and then causes one more day to
happen
you ever seen captain america have to go
to the dmv to get his plates renewed no
siree but anyway every episode has a
nice little example of peter's home life
in his superhero life
being at odds and one of the dramatic
strengths of the character is how when
peter parker succeeds typically
spider-man loses
and vice versa this cartoon has a better
grasp on this character than 95
of his twitter fandom who keep arguing
about whether or not he's a pessimist or
an optimist
or whether he wants iron man to be his
dad or he wants to punch him here's one
of my favorite moments from the show
where it just felt like pure
unadulterated spider-man brought to life
well too deep life drawn on
cells and the sandman accidentally tears
off spidey's mask in a fight and he has
to scramble away like a punk to figure
out how to conceal his face again before
going after him
this is a cool setup and i gotta give
props to the animators for working in a
scenario where peter's face is visible
during an action
scene it's probably not as cheap or easy
to animate his facial expressions during
a fast and energetic scene like this but
they went the extra mile that the 60s
show wouldn't have touched with a
10-foot pole
which would have been poorly inserted
into one of the six pre-rendered shots
that you've seen five or six times
already in the last 22 minutes
then there's some great moments with j
jonah jameson bantering back and forth
with the trapped spidey
i uh wonder if you could spare a helping
hand don't
[Music]
oh great you can pass out snapchats at
my funeral and a cool ending where our
hero uses both personas to get a
personal victory for himself
there's plenty of cool episodes in this
show that feel very worthy of the
character
if you can stomach a few that shove in
some villains that were just popular at
the time
both magneto and doctor doom appear in
this show
with doom having a very disproportionate
amount of screen time for whatever
reason
in fact i think doom is the main villain
in the intro
he appears more times in that opening
credits than even green goblin damn
there are four different episodes with
him as the main villain while vulture
goblin sandman lizard chameleon and
craven
all just get one the villain roster is
also padded out with a few original
characters too
i understood why that happened in the
60s cartoon but
at this point there had been 20 years
worth of new villains to choose from so
there wasn't really much of an excuse to
not
use them however something kind of cool
about this show is that not every
episode
has an origin for their villains and
this show implies that spidey's been
around for a while and seems to know who
some of these chumps are
and unlike the 60s cartoon this one
definitely had a better grasp of how to
use green goblin
and adapts a classic spidey story with
norman osborne recovering from amnesia
and remembering spidey's identity after
a battle a few years ago caused him to
forget
perfect just in time to find
spider-man without his mask
and think what the shock will do to you
[Music]
that's even neil ross the same green
goblin voice actor from the 90s show
but what of spidey's trademark girl
problems who does he pine for in this
show
well gwen stacy and mary jane aren't
here
but betty bran is
okay and much like the 60s cartoon i
wish that wasn't the case
but he just gets angry at him constantly
complains and says he's a shitty
boyfriend but then keeps going out with
him anyway
if the guy was such a flake then stop
messing with him and get with a real man
like
flash thompson he's venom sometimes but
then peter comes to his senses and
decides to get with someone who
understands him
medusa from the inhumans i'm not joking
that's how the show ends
he saves medusa from being controlled by
a villain and then they hook up
love hey who would i be in love with
not the redhead you were expecting but
i'll take it
when this series goes for direct spidey
stories it does a pretty solid job of
adapting them and really captures the
zany
cheesiness of his comics from that time
as well as how in those stories spidey
and his villains usually take this goofy
stuff
deadly serious and even when it's trying
to tell an original story
it does an okay job of making that fit
the tone and themes of spider-man anyway
and even sometimes has some superhero
crossovers which were a new thing in
superhero cartoons at the time there's a
bit of a problem prioritizing which
villains to use but it has a decent take
on all the classics
i like this one a lot i'd say this is
the first really great attempt at a
spidey cartoon after the 60s show
started to lose the plot a little due to
budgetary concerns
if you like good old john spiderman in
his chaotic day-to-day life check it out
but you could come with me this is where
i belong then
farewell you'll never escape again
murderer
[Music]
have you ever wanted a show where
spider-man replicates what was most
popular in that era of cartoons
groups of hip young platonic teens going
on adventures with a silly cartoon dog
sidekick
well if you did then look what you did
you monster
in fact iceman looks and sounds just
like fred jones
i don't believe this miss lion
though the dog might be more of an
attempt to ape off of super friends
in this show spidey teams up with his
gbf and will they won't they gal pal
coriander of tamarans the three of them
have powers based on the four
elements fire ice and spiders
[Music]
you're gonna get a big charge out of
this
[Music]
for the people in the marvel universe to
saddle spidey with his permanent
sidekicks
i feel like iceman was a really random
choice and then making an original
character was even more confusing
apparently they couldn't get the human
torch due to some licensing issues which
is why he was replaced with a dumbass
robot in that other cartoon
so angelica jones was created and looks
way too much like mary jane
the three of them sleep in the same
bedroom and aunt mae's house
which she's now renting out as a
polyamory friendly bed and breakfast
i appreciate how fireman and ice star
aren't super intrusive
this still feels like a spider-man show
through and through
they aren't posited as spidey's equals
and shoved into his spotlight they know
their place
title should have been spider-man and
his subservient bottoms
so i bet you're wondering this looks a
lot like the 1981 series
is this a sequel to that well that's
kind of confusing and hard to answer
especially considering both shows
started airing on the same day
spider-man was popular back then i guess
whatever turns you on turns me on too
spidey darling
so uh spider-man's voice is different
now he's voiced by original bumblebee
voice actor dan gilvison
you whipper snappers may also recognize
him as spider-man 2099 in shattered
dimensions
well sometimes it seems like the shows
are connected spider friends has a
flashback to the magneto episode of the
80s cartoon but both of them portray
green goblin very differently
with one going the split personality
costume change route
the other making it seem like he's not
wearing a costume he just actually
physically turns green and crazy both
shows cover the origin in different ways
there's also a lot of continuity errors
with what's going on with red skull and
doom
so my prognosis is no these shows are
not connected
they just share some footage in one spot
where it could save them some money
and you know use similar music and
character designs but
outside of that they're happening in
different timelines and that really
shows in the tone of both shows a swim
is just what i need to revive my
strength
that's not water it's alcohol
this show is the true spiritual
successor to the 60s cartoon in that it
recreates the signature style of having
two episode types
decent adaptations of comic story lines
and bizarro bat [ __ ] insane buffoonery
where spider-man feels out of place
because everything around him is so
strange
like an episode where they adapt the
first appearance of green goblin
you know that weird storyline where he
tricks spider-man into starring in a
fake movie about himself for money as a
trap
then tries to murder him then the hulk
randomly shows up because they were in
the cave he was staying in at the time
except the show did that better because
they swapped out goblin with mysterio
who is a villain already associated with
deception in hollywood so it works way
better
good on you you retroactively fixed a
really stupid story that even deadpool
thought was a weird intro for spidey's
nemesis
then there's the other type of episodes
rover on his bugs and spidey has bug
eyes over his costume
bug eyes in an episode where he dates an
alien girl
in an episode where electro traps flash
thompson in a video game in an episode
where iceman comes out to his parents
an episode for firestar marries dracula
more often than not in both types of
episodes the villain is always watching
our heroes and torturing them from a
control room full of monitors
i like to think in the marvel universe
there's some company out there selling
super computers and various monitors
whose sole customer base is super
villains trying to kill the spider
friends
you can tell which episodes i'm more of
a fan of the weird random stuff doesn't
do it for me but there are a handful of
original episode story lines that are
terrible and feel a bit more grounded
wait i know see you back at the gym
boy that student really rigged up the
wires
[Music]
wires and even if not every episode hits
for me i do like the look of this show a
lot
same cool character designs but
occasionally some pretty detailed
shading and it even slips into like an
80s anime style
i suspect because a few portions were
animated by different studios or had
considerably more money
if i were to pick some episodes that
were worth checking out i'd say the
origin ones are all good but then the
x-men crossover is pretty cool and i
really wore out the vhs tape i had of it
as a kid
it's not the best spidey series but it's
still got some merit
spidey's the same hero we know and love
and it's not so bad having a few friends
to tag along since they make sure the
spotlight stays on him
it's clear this show did resonate with
some people though because it's always
being referenced in one form or another
in the comics and
firestar managed to carry over to the
books eventually it still got that same
spider-man charm
just with backup this time
i'm ready to chuck it all give up being
spider-man
here no way buddy boy what happened to
that
great lesson you learned yes with great
power
comes great responsibility
okay okay i'm gonna do the night in the
next one
um if that takes a couple months please
don't be angry at me i i
will be soon it won't take seven months
probably but
but like just be patient okay be patient
i got stuff to do
be patient
[Music]
you